This is a family business.
Daddy's faculties are... waning.
The next logical leaders
would be Amber and myself.
Y'all are not the only
married people in this family.
Me and BJ are also
strongly betrothed.
Not a real family, no kids.
Slam! I like that one.
JUDY GEMSTONE:
I don't got time for kids
'cause I'm tryin' to keep
this fresh physique fine.
I'm not tryin' to be all loose
and stretched out
like Amber's
played-out pastrami.
Enough!
♪ This is a house
That Jack built y'all ♪
♪ ("THE HOUSE THAT JACK BUILT"
BY ARETHA FRANKLIN PLAYS) ♪
♪ Remember this house ♪
Jesse and I are blessed
to be teaming up with Lyle
and Lindy Lissons
on a new business venture.
LYLE LISSONS: Zion's Landing.
It's a Christian
time-share resort
on the sunny beaches of Florida.
We got to align ourselves
with the best.
I mean only pure thoroughbreds.
-That's exactly
how we see y'all too.
-We do.
As powerful,
Christian horses-type folks.
♪ I turned my back on Jack ♪
♪ He said he wasn't coming back
I turned my back on Jack ♪
This is Junior,
a friend of mine from Memphis.
Who's this hot piece of tail?
That's my daughter, Judy.
Oh, excuse me. And, uh,
this one of her girlfriends?
Well, I'm not a lesbian partner.
I'm her husband, BJ.
-No, BJ. He's big dicking you.
-(BURST OF LAUGHTER)
There's something else
y'all should be aware of.
A reporter is in our backyard.
I'm doing a piece
on your family.
You think I haven't tussled
with the press before?
Well, the story I got
isn't on you.
Don't dance around. Which one
of my family are you after?
Who are you tryin' to smear?
We are
in this reporter's crosshairs.
Let's go save
our fucking family.
♪ ("SPIRIT IN THE DARK"
BY ARETHA FRANKLIN PLAYS) ♪
You gonna
try to blackmail me?
Sell the story?
Let's not waste time.
You don't know
who you're messin' with.
Now, I'm on the way up,
and you on the way down.
Gunmen just tried
to assassinate your father.
(GUNFIRE)
Kelvin, open the door!
(CAR BEEPS)
-Son of a--
-Open the fucking door!
I'm trying!
Don't you know how to use
your fucking car?!
All we have to do
is just think for a second.
No, we don't have to think!
We have to drive!
All right, my door's fucking
opening back up now!
-I'm trying!
-God dammit!
♪ Move with the spirit ♪